Hello, the internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We are The Slow-Mo Guys
and we have balls.
We do have balls, two balls, in fact.
And a big air compressor.
Yeah, does up to 110 PSI, compression.
What is the sort of rated
PSI of a sports ball?
10, maybe.
So absolutely gonna annihilate it.
They're gonna get destroyed.
So we'll--
Got footy
and an American footy.
So I'm going to have to
pump it up 'til it's, like,
sort of maximum, maybe 15
PSI, something like that, 20.
Risking it.
Shove the needle in, wind up
building up pressure in here,
and then I'm gonna crank
up the volume to max
and just sort of run away,
I'm gonna run away as soon as that starts
and hit the button.
You're gonna have 2.5
seconds to press the button,
you think you can manage it?
I can handle the pressure.
Whoa!
I thought it was gonna go
before I had the chance to get back.
I felt it and I was like
"That's rock hard."
Really?
Yeah!
Flippin' heck!
Whoa!
Whoa, flip!
Look how wrinkly it
goes at the other side.
You can see the leather splits,
then the, sort of air balloon comes out
and then that splits.
Yeah, in such a quick time, as well.
This is what happened when I absolutely
Roberto Carlosed it into the top corner.
Absolutely annihilated itself.
Ripped apart all the stitching.
Did you ever play football
with just the inner bit?
Yeah.
I remember my France '98 ball.
It sort of disintegrated on the outside--
That's exactly what happened to mine.
We ended up having like a bubble of it out
and it was just like
going around everywhere.
So we just pulled it out and
played with the inner bit.
Brings back some memories.
All right, so that's a real football done.
Maybe do an American football next.
Pretend football, okay, sure.
A hand egg, maybe.
Hey wait, wait, wait, laces out.
Which, like this?
Hello, I'm Zippy!
You do some Rainbow?
Rainbow.
Can you do Bungle?
What does he sound like?
Oh, forget it.
This one split down the
width of it, it seems.
Yeah, look what happens
when I play American football once.
I burst the ball.
Was that your first interaction
with an American football?
Yeah, it was, yeah.
It almost turned itself inside out.
It like, blew itself around itself.
It went like, wrinkly like that.
Yeah, and then just buggered off.
That was terrifying!
Scary, isn't it?
Imagine if your hand was right there,
you'd just get blown to bits.
The rupture wound of a pressure build up,
it's so different, like you just,
that's the only way that could happen,
into shreds like that.
Yeah, it looks like someone's
taken scissors to it.
Yeah.
It's weird.
This one really opened up.
Well hopefully you enjoyed
that mindless piece of destruction.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
We also have a second
channel, and we have merch.
We're also starting a new line of hats.
Oh yeah, these make good hats, actually.
Pretty effective.
Yours looks way better than mine.
You're like some sort of sultan or like--
You look like Dan Aykroyd.
Right there.
Like some sort of Middle
Eastern royalty, I like it.
Okay, thanks for watching that video.
And we'll see you next time.
Not the smartest one we ever made.
Well, anything that ends like this
can't be the smartest thing we've made.
Sorry.